so after those nine people said no who
shows up
his brother shows up and um who comes
through i come through
um and then what do i get for it but you
know three months of uh
of bullying and grief on set
jerry jerry was the first of um
a trilogy of movies that gus ended up
making
that had a very unique style inspired by
a period in russian filmmaking that
tarkovsky was a part of
that gus was interested in the idea for
the story came about
from an article that gus had read about
two
young men who had pulled over on a road
trip on the side of the road
and they followed signs for some kind of
roadside attraction
and they got lost as they were walking
straight from the path
accidentally in a place where it's very
hard to tell whether or not you're
actually on the path or not one of those
kind of desert
desert hikes where everything looks the
same they were lost for three days in
the desert
and dehydration can be very painful and
one of them
um was pretty sure that they were dying
and couldn't walk anymore
and asked the other one to kill him we
were all at a friend's house gus and
matt and i were having lunch at a friend
a cinematographer named bobby bukowski's
house and
arvo part was playing on the stereo and
gus heard that music and i think it sort
of all came together for him but maybe
he would say that's
stupid i that was that's my memory of it
and so we wrote a script about
those based on those two guys it was
minimalist and it did have a lot of
talking in it
but the story was was pretty
straightforward and simple they get out
of the car
they walk they get lost they keep
walking we tried to
shoot it in jordan and there's a travel
advisory at the time and so
decided not to we ended up in argentina
where somehow it was overlooked that it
was winter
uh in the southern hemisphere so we got
down to the desert and on day one it was
snowing
um so we did our best to sort of fake
things until gus decided that he wanted
to just
go back to try to shoot it in the states
and we ended up in death valley
the assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford
the novel was is almost perfect i mean
it's just
it is perfect describe robert ford in a
way
that i felt like when i finished reading
it which i had done before i even
auditioned the first time
i felt like i understood him better than
any character i'd ever played already
it's just a beautiful piece of writing
and it isn't about jesse james it is
about
robert ford you're the youngest of three
james boys and i'm the youngest of five
forward boys
between charlie and me is another
brother wilbur here with six letters in
his name
and between frank and you is another
brother robert also with six letters
and my christian name is robert of
course but working with andrew
he's just a master i don't know how he
knows uh so much about
directing actors because he had only
done one other movie before jesse james
he really is a genius with it it's like
sort of
explaining the psychology of of the
characters in the scenes so he helped a
lot
and between andrew and and the novel
there was i didn't have to do any any
other research but i did read a lot of
these nickel and dime books this is what
these like little cartoon books were
called in that period
and just james was someone who people
only knew him
as the in the way that we know now it
was already had already been sort of
mythologized in a way of
instead of you know people thought of
him as this
kind of glamorous gun-fighting robin
hood figure
which just wasn't the case he was a
serial killer basically
very very violent criminal hoping that
safe
but people had this idea even it didn't
even wait till he was dead they had
already people have been writing about
him and the sort of bank robberies and
things that were happening in the
frontier
that no one had any personal experience
with back in the
you know on the east coast there was
this mythologization that had happened
that that robert four as a young man he
was reading those books
and that was the idea that he had of
jesse james in his in his mind
so when he crossed paths with him for
the first time when he met him i think
it was confusing
disappointing but it was also hard for
him to divorce himself
from this picture that he had of him um
being this
like larger than life hero he really
wasn't he didn't give his money away
uh he killed a lot of people it was
selfish and violent and murderous
as he got to know who the real jesse
james was he became sort of
bitter and disillusioned in a sort of
resentful way i think
any story that is about fame and fans
you know people are going to draw
parallels to
hollywood and they make sense but andrew
wasn't doing that overtly and neither
was ron hanson
i think they were just sort of telling
story as it was but those were ideas
that came to everybody's mind
it was a sort of dawning of a new era of
uh that kind of thing people were
becoming famous
while they were alive there was a
distortion of facts and a
misrepresentation of those personalities
through the depiction
in popular media so
it brings to mind you know the
relationship between fans and
hollywood stars you know there's an old
saying about um
actors that has to go hollywood is a
place where they put people under
contract and they should be putting them
under observation
and that was sort of true for jesse
james he'd become this hero and he was
just a lunatic
and maybe true now with a certain people
who get famous
[Music]
gone baby gone i was shooting jesse
james at the time which was kind of a
big break for me it was a studio movie
it was warner brothers and
you know brad pitt was in it and it was
one of the best things i'd ever read so
it was something that
i really really wanted i auditioned for
it you know seven
times i had to fight hard for it because
nobody knew who i was and nobody
wanted to put me as the lead of a bigger
movie like that when i got that part it
was a big break
and i think that ben had a list of about
10 people that he was trying to cast in
gone baby gone
and he went down the first nine people
and they said no and then he got to me
and
i was shooting jesse james at the time
and i think people were
willing to let him cast me because i was
doing that movie and people thought that
it was going to be
um kind of a successful movie so after
those nine people said no
who shows up his brother shows up and um
who comes through i come through and
then what do i get for it but you know
three months of uh of bullying and grief
on set
how's that good now you know
you're [ __ ] miles closed then we shot
that
in boston and it was actually a really
great experience i knew that ben was
going to be
a good director and nobody else sort of
knew him the way that i did i think
people just thought of him
they all they knew was him as the person
they'd seen in the movies that he'd done
up to that point he'd never directed
anything
i knew he was a very smart guy and super
talented and it's one of the movies that
i
look back on and think that if i could
do it now it would be a lot better i
would like to tackle one of those other
books that's in that series and try to
do it now
it was a first for me and it was also a
first for ben so there was kind of a big
learning curve i think we could do
another one
it would be great
ain't them body saints no i'm not going
to leave you
nobody cause i will leave you first it's
not
funny i'm not going to leave you
i didn't know anybody at all i didn't
know rooney i didn't know
david um i had no idea really going into
it how lucky i was to be involved in
that project what i found was that
they're all
just incredibly talented rooney's such a
special
actor and i think david will emerge as
one of the
one of the great american filmmakers
he's so prolific
and everything he does is different all
of his movies have a
kind of david lowry signature about them
as well it kind of reminds me of the
coen brothers how
they're all different but you can sort
of tell that they made them i don't know
sort of a perfect fit for me i was glad
that i
took that leap of faith because it's
true i didn't know anything about them
i had seen his um short film called
pioneer
which was great but it was a five minute
shot of somebody telling
a bedtime story you know he could have
turned out to be
uh any kind of filmmaker but he turned
out to be the kind of filmmaker that i
really love
working with and i love watching his
movies i can relate to people who are
misunderstood
i can relate to people who feel like
they're outsiders i've been living in la
for
20 years or whatever and i feel like an
outsider in the industry and
those kinds of parts are easy for me to
relate to
[Music]
out of the furnace so that was a
character who had come back from
war and uh was having a hard time
adjusting
found like these kind of backyard fights
as a way of dealing with that stress
people kind of beating each other up and
someone videotaping it people bet on it
and i watched some of that stuff
online because it was out there i did
talk to people who
had come back from from um service
overseas and
fighting and i also just watched a lot
of stuff online you can kind of find
anything online
it makes doing research really easy you
can just find interviews with people who
have done just about anything in their
life or
are dealing with different things and it
was really helpful
and i have a lot of friends who are in
the military uh
who i was able to talk to it's some
weird thing that happens where it's
really hard to be bad around people that
are really good
they kind of make everyone better than
they would be and that's
i think that was the case for me and for
uh zoe saldana and christian bale and
woody harrelson it you know
there's something about um christian who
i did most of my stuff with it it's just
so good whatever whatever he's doing it
sort of rubs off on other people
around him when i started that movie i
remember on my first day of shooting
that movie we were doing a scene where i
went to visit him in prison
so we did one scene in the morning and
then i felt like
it kind of sucked and i told him that i
didn't feel that i had done a good job
i said it was my first day which was
always really hard and then i felt sort
of lost and he said
oh lost is great like loss is a good a
good thing to feel
and that was sort of the perfect
response and it made me
just relax and also gave me some insight
to
how he works and and how to be a better
actor
[Music]
manchester by the sea
i really didn't create that character i
just sort of stepped in and tried to do
what i could
bring to life what kenny had created and
everything he writes
is done so carefully and with such
detail and
there are a lot of people writers who
would like you to not change lines and
there are some that really want you to
improvise and change things and they're
more collaborative
uh i think for good reason kenny's very
very very specific
and i don't think that there's one
single um or ah that i said in that
movie that wasn't scripted
um
i don't have anything big to say it's
okay the script was
at one time over 300 pages when i read
it it was
i don't know 180 or 90. he has so much
material and
uh he just compacts it into a you know
eventually down into a normal sized
screenplay
but um the result is that it's dense
with with
meaning and it's really carefully done
you know he's one of those people that
knows every movie just you know back to
the 1930s and he can
reference certain scenes and moments and
movies that you've never heard of and
you go back and you watch them and they
really help
to play the scene that you're playing in
the movie right now and
um i would say that i just sort of
followed his lead as
as much as i could and everyone in that
in that movie was so good but
working with michelle williams you stop
thinking about yourself you're just
trying to
keep up with with her and react to her
in the moment because
she's just uh incredible yeah i did
watch it i was forced to watch it it was
at the sundance film festival which is a
great festival
uh but they like people to stick around
see they sort of introduced you
beforehand or whatever and then
i went and sat in a seat that had my
name on it i wasn't sitting with the
rest of the
people i don't know where they were in
the movie so i was sitting next to a
stranger
who at the end of every scene you know
your shoulder shoulder with a stranger
she would be watching the movie and then
just sort of look at me
turn and look at me as if to say like
what'd you think about that
so it was a really strange experience
and i didn't want to say like
you know whisper like would you would
you mind
not looking at me and just watching the
movie so it just went on like that for
the whole two hours
um so i did watch the movie
but i had that happening
[Music]
a ghost story you know david called me
up and said do you want to do something
kind of make a small movie on her own
for 20 days and i just said yes
i don't think that i read anything
eventually i did read something but it
was it's just an outline
it i think it was a 10-page outline that
described what happened in it but i
would have said yes without that
um those are my favorite people to work
with and it's just
i love meeting new people and uh it
always brings something
new out of you when you go onto a set
and there's a bunch of new people
and you can kind of leave who you were
behind and just
allow yourself to be someone completely
new that's fun
it's like going to a new summer camp or
something but i would also say
i'd be i'd have no complaints if people
said you're just going to work with that
same group over and over um
from anything by saints and ghost story
and and the old man in the gun
uh just some of my best friends in the
world and
um and they're also people who
i always feel like i'm being challenged
and the nicest possible
way to be a little bit better than i am
it was the best experience i don't know
why there's something about making being
able to
be an actor and make choices to play a
scene but not be seen
that's universal to humans when they put
on a mask they feel
kind of free free of being seen
free of something is happening like
psychologically that makes you
lose your self-consciousness in a way
that works as a
it's good for being an actor i loved it
[Music]
light of my life the first thing that i
wrote for light of my life
was a bedtime story that i had told my
kids and i
thought like oh it's a pretty good story
and i went and i wrote it down
um and i think my oldest son was
five so that was about 11 years ago and
then i started writing down other
other little stories and also other
conversations that i would have with
with my kids
things spring up on you and little
moments or fights the kids get into or
things you think suddenly happen and you
think it's supposed to be a teaching
moment you're supposed to like teach the
moment and i
um and you don't always say the right
thing you know
and then that night you sitting there
thinking about it and just think
damn it why didn't i why did i say that
why didn't i say this other thing
i sometimes i would write down those
conversations too because i thought that
they were really interesting and i just
wanted to remember them i sort of
collected them
collecting them into a kind of story
about a father and
and two boys and then i pieced together
a story i thought it would be pretty
boring and so i wanted to give it some
sort of
like backdrop that was going to be some
story with the spine that might be kind
of suspenseful and hold people's
attention and also i love those movies i
love kind of
apocalypse movies and road warrior and
things like that and i told my kids
about it
and my kids said uh immediately they had
no response for whether or not it was
good or bad or they interested
they were just adamant they don't they
were like you're not going to make that
into a movie are you
and i was kind of like well i was
planning on it
uh and they said you cannot make a movie
about us so i changed it then from two
from a father and two boys to a story
about a father and a daughter
thinking that that would relieve them of
their their anxiety about
uh being embarrassed that their dad had
made a movie about them so
then i wound up with a dad and a
daughter a new story
about a young girl
don't make it about me i'm not making
about you
then the rest of the writing came out of
just imagining the circumstances of
some giant pandemic has spread across
the globe
and destabilized everything to the point
of
sort of lawlessness but trying to
imagine what that would be like
realistically
in a world where people don't want to
give up on everything
i just thought like if a pandemic came
people probably wouldn't just like
you know immediately like make their you
know cars look like mad max and just go
running into the streets and tribes and
i think that they would probably
there would be a certain level of
normalcy that would be sustained
like their comforts and their things and
their their houses and their tvs and
their routines that they have and so i
started to build the story around that
sort of what how do you combine those
two things
a pandemic that has killed half the
population and
destabilized all the governments and
infrastructure
but that you're still a parent you still
have a kid and you're still hoping to
kind of raise them in a way that they
can be happy healthy
people um and take care of themselves
you know there's some things that you
get to decide and there's some things
that you don't
well what do i decide you get to decide
what kind of attitude you're going to
have when you have to do things that you
don't want to do
then i used all those stories and
conversations that i had written
uh between me and my my own kids and
then sort of tailored them to a world
that had
just you know gone nuts a little bit i
remember sort of calling david lowry
uh as in the middle of a very
about what i felt like was a very
complicated sequence i had one day to
shoot
all the action in that movie uh which
takes place near the end
and i hadn't really worked it out and
his advice he said if you make a little
dollhouse and you get little action
figures
you can stage all of the action and you
can shoot it with a teeny tiny
like your phone or something and then
you'll know how you want to do it in
which i did that
best advice i got and the best thing i
did to prepare
and help me know exactly how to kind of
piece all that stuff together
[Music]
the old man in the gun so i had done
manchester by the sea
and had no i nobody thought that we
would be promoting that movie for that
long or that it would have that
that kind of uh successful run that it
did that would
require our attention so i was supposed
to be
making um a lighter my light in my life
and
i had to go back you know to help
promote the movie while i was making
light of my life which was really weird
it also meant that
i wasn't able to do either one with the
same level of
sort of focus that i would have liked
but whatever and then i
i uh when i started shooting light of my
life david lowry is gearing up to do
old man on the gun and um
so the minute i wrapped uh light of my
life
i got on a plane and then you know the
next day i was in cincinnati filming and
i had never done that
usually when i work i do a movie and
then it takes me another year to find a
movie to do
uh i just have never had the kind of
career where people have been waiting to
work with me you know while i'm
doing something else and i can just kind
of roll into them so i didn't really
know what that was like
it was hard to adjust from just doing
just finishing one movie that was so
all-consuming because i had written it
and i was acting in it and i was
directing it
and there was only two people in the
movie to then sort of just trying to
forget about that
and go you know get out of play and go
to cincinnati and shoot the old man the
gun
and it was too bad because the old man
on the gun was something i was so
excited about uh robert redford had been
you know like he was for anyone who's
ever worked in movies and not worked in
movies so many of them he was a hero of
mine growing up and
for as long as i can remember i remember
being a very little kid watching this
thing
learning all the lines and um imitating
his gestures
and you know same with the natural and
he's just had done some of my most
favorite movies um
and then you know i get to go and work
with him and on top of it it's his last
movie that he said and on top of it he's
playing a bank robber
which you know he's maybe one of the
most beloved outlaws
uh ever in movies so it was just a
huge treat for me i was really excited
and
i was bummed that i sort of felt like i
had no time to
prepare for it
[Music]
our friend when i read the script and i
talked to gabriella carperthwaite who
directed it
um i realized that she just wanted to
make her own
version of this story what was important
to her
was that the things that were meaningful
about the story
be conveyed in a way that was effective
and moving for the audience
and that she didn't care so much about
how
similar i was to matigue but matt had
written an article about his experience
with his wife when she had cancer
and raising his two kids and with his
friend
helping him out and that article was
pretty informative i mean it was there
wasn't a lot left
out so i felt like i had a lot of matt
already going into it both in the
article and in the way that brad
inglesby had written the screenplay
um that i had plenty and knowing that
gabriella wanted to then you know wisely
decided that
it was her responsibility to make a
movie that works with this story
and not make a movie that is as accurate
as it can be to every little thing that
happened in their life but that didn't
work no one would want to see that so
what she wound up making was something
that was accurate and that also
is quite moving so she made the right
choice
but i didn't feel like i had to um mimic
or portray someone in the way that you
know if you're gonna play
kennedy or something you wanna um you
know people are pretty familiar with
what he's like and that playing that
role is going to require
sort of having people believe that you
are him
i didn't have that responsibility it was
a movie about people who were showing up
for one another and you know someone
said that like a
great friend is someone who who is there
with you when there is
he would rather be anywhere else in the
world and that's what
dane is this is a story of matigue who's
losing his wife and it's a story of a
woman nicole who
is a mom and has been so many things and
is also there are so many things that
she didn't get to be in life
who and she knows that she only has a
certain amount of time left
and their friend who comes into their
life to help them
um at that at that time that's why it's
called our friend that was just touching
to me
i just like that relationships are very
important to me and i like that
uh what this movie said about
relationships
um and it wasn't just the character dane
played by jason siegel who kind of shows
up for everybody
it's everyone you know dakota johnson
such a great job playing nicole
she she's showing up for her family
she's going through
in a really really tough time and she is
showing up
for her kids and um and for her husband
too
who kind of crumbles at times in a way
that's just beautiful i mean i remember
when i had someone in my life who was in
their 90s who was dying and
i sat with them and i would see everyone
who came to say goodbye to them
ended up needing to be comforted and
there he was
sort of frail and in the last moments of
life comforting
each person one by one as they came to
him and i just thought like what
amazing that is the strength and wisdom
of somebody who's lived 90 years
on earth they can't even you know move a
muscle in their body but they have this
great inner strength to
to be there for other people to walk
help them through that moment
of saying goodbye and nicole in this
story
had that strength after only for
30 some years and so that's what makes
her such an incredible character and
dakota did such a good job playing it
she had to betray
the painful journey of of having a
terrible disease
and also she had to play the character
who was by all accounts in real life the
kind of person who
just lights up a room and reminds you
of what a gift life is without ever
having to say it and make you feel
instructed or lectured
just by being around her people
remembered how much fun it was to be
alive
so she had to be that part and also be
showing
people what it was like to be dying of
cancer a really hard part
and i thought she did a great job with
it
[Music]
the world to come when i had done the
assassination of jesse james by the cow
driver ford
i met ron hanson who was the novelist
that that movie was based on
his novel and then i read all of his
books and he's just one of my favorite
writers
and i became friends with them uh and i
asked him about eight years ago or
something
if there was if he wanted to write a
screenplay if there's something else
that he wanted to do
and he sent me two stories one was about
a baseball player in cuba and the other
was about
two women who fall in love in the 19th
century on a farm
now i had been to cuba when i was a
little kid and i'd grown up playing
baseball i still play baseball i love it
and so that felt perfect to me
but when i read the story about these
two women in the 19th century on a farm
i've never lived in a farm
i'm not from the 19th century not a
woman but it was such a moving story
that
i just felt like that was the that was
the one that i wanted to be a part of
and i was planning on
directing it and ron and jim shepard who
was the
author of the story together they wrote
the screenplay
and it took about six years because they
both have other jobs so they're doing
this on the side and they're not getting
paid
and it's one of the best scripts that
i've ever read it became
clear to me that it was a great
opportunity
to find a female director and have her
direct the movie but it definitely felt
like the right thing to do and mona
fastfold came on
she'd made an one other movie
sleepwalker
and she just took to it immediately and
she
made the brilliant choice of casting
catherine larson and vanessa kirby
those are the first two people cast and
really hard parts to play
and mona was so right they were just
perfect for it so then
you know we had to figure out how to
raise the money and
um for you know us just someone who'd
only done one other movie
and with actresses who at that time it
was harder to get financed and so
now they are being recognized as for
you know their talents and for all the
things that they are
we just stuck with it and um finally we
got
got the money to make it and we went and
shot it in transylvania which was really
interesting
because it was mostly the two of them um
every day you know they had they had the
bulk of the work um
i had days off here and there because i
was acting in it as well
and um so i would trip around and
go look at all the vampire stuff in
transylvania jacqueline isn't real but
um he was very loosely based on some
real person but the castle that they
have for tourists this dracula's castle
isn't even the place where that guy ever
lived i was bummed about my transylvania
experience in that way but
um it's a really beautiful country and
it did make me want to do a vampire
movie
looking back i realized that the things
that came my way had something to do
with the kind of person that i was
and when i got to a point in my career
where i could choose
work which isn't always the case it sort
of comes and goes nothing
nothing recedes like success there were
times when
i got to pick parts that i wanted to do
and there are times
when i didn't when i was choosing the
parts i i thought i was picking them for
one reason
but very often looking back i realized
that they were still sort of picking me
and it had to do with sort of who i was
in a way that i didn't even really
realize